(upbeat techo music)
- I'm never interested
in bullshitting.
We are going to,
not a mobile first world,
we're going to
a mobile-only world.
AI and automation
will never stop.
We're gonna become robots.
And nostalgia is the most
under-priced
asset in our society.
I can buy a business
for $80 million,
and sell it for $4.6 billion.
Can we win?
Like can we fuckin' sell shit?
Losing is comfortable.
Losing is delicious.
There's just no other gear.
Your destiny is your destiny.
It's on you.
I just don't even
know how not to be me.
- I know we said we weren't
gonna have any speakers
at this event,
but I didn't say Q and A's.
So, we're very,
super grateful that Gary
was able to join us.
Most of you, anybody
not familiar with Gary?
It's a pretty tuned in audience!
- [Gary] It motivates me!
- Well yeah, there's a
lot of people, obviously,
there was a little
bit of a procession
when he was coming in,
almost like a wedding
or something like that.
Super excited, Gary's here
for just a little bit.
I know he has a conference
call right around the corner,
so we're just gonna go
right into a Q and A.
Gary's amazing
when it comes to rants,
it's funny how I actually
decided on Gary.
We did a comedian in year
two of Mastermind Talks,
during a dinner.
And it was so well received,
and I was like, man it's be
great to have like a comedian
who actually could deliver
great business stuff,
and I was like fuck,
Gary's hilarious!
So, that's why
we have Gary here.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
no introduction needed,
Gary Vaynerchuk!
(applause)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Super pumped to be here.
Obviously a lot of friends
that I know intimately,
so that makes it a lot of fun.
Yeah, you know,
obviously a lot of
what I've been focused on
for the last couple years
has been to
actually push my brand
into a place where
I could go to an event
and just do Q and A.
Which I think
at the end of the day,
knowing so many of you,
I'm and will always be concerned
about can I bore people?
Can it become boring?
And there's a lot of
you that really know me,
the truth is there's so
few things I believe in.
There's really only three
or four true kind of like
principles that I believe in.
Luckily for me, and
luckily for so many of us,
we got to live during this
era where everything changes
so much.
I'm baffled by people not
understanding what happens
when we move
to a Snapchat universe,
all the same shit that happened
on every other platform
that had people's attention,
whether it's print or radio,
television, or Facebook,
so for me, thank God that
the markets gonna move
on an everyday basis and
thank God people get old.
And what I mean
by people getting old
is at South by Southwest
it was funny.
Chris Sacca exposed this thing
in his big Vanity Fair piece,
which we make fun of,
but for years we had
this very small group
that at South-by would get
together at like midnight
and go in literally
just a small hotel room,
just sit there
and we would basically,
we called it the jam session,
all it was was
literally "Is Pinterest
worth a billion dollars?"
"What do you think is
gonna happen with Uber?"
and we did that for
seven or eight years,
it was really interesting
to see where people
were right and wrong,
and it was just amazing
debates and I learned so much.
But to me the
Q and A and the banter
and the content
is so imperative.
It was two years ago at the
jam session where literally
the founders,
the founders of Twitter
and Instagram and these
tools poo-poohed Snapchat.
And like just really,
it was crazy.
I was literally emphatically
yelling at them,
like you guys changed
the world, and everybody
said the same shit about
your product five years ago,
how did you get so old so fast?
(audience laughs)
And so you know, obviously
whether it's entrepreneurship
or investing or
running a company,
I think for the people here
that have had the time,
'cause I know some
of you are so busy,
in the last six months to a
year I've been spending a lot
more time on what really
has allowed me the privilege
of standing in
front of you which is,
I'm not really IQ strong,
I'm really probably,
I would actually argue
that I'm probably
below-average to average on IQ,
but I do think my parents
blessed me with over-the-top EQ,
and my emotional intelligence
and self-awareness and
empathy and the way
I built my, you know,
the reason VaynerMedia has
gone from 30 to 650 people
and hasn't broke is
predicated so much on EQ.
And then consumer behavior,
like projecting what
I think you guys are gonna do
before you realize
you're gonna do it,
has a little bit to do
with that stuff as well.
So, thrilled to go anywhere,
I'm real excited to do Q and
A and thanks for having me.
Are you guys gonna mic it?
You gonna run it?
Great.
Let's just get into it.
Just name and question.
- [Cameron] Cameron Herold,
I've got a question
regarding second in command.
I ran a session today about
your Chief Operating Officer.
I wanna know who is
running VaynerMedia for you
and what makes the relationship
between you and
that person so strong.
- So that's an
interesting question,
and an interesting time
to ask that question.
This Friday, my brother
A.J. who's been the C.O.O.
of VaynerMedia
from the beginning
is leaving the company.
I think some of you might
have read a month ago
AJ finally announced,
cause he's been
very private about it,
my brother has Crohn's Disease.
And truth is, and I know
some of you know AJ,
AJ and I are really different,
just like I'm much more,
I mean AJ is thrilled
to have his seven friends
and I'm desperate
to be deep friends
with every fucking
person in here.
(laughter)
And so AJ was no question
the C.O.O. of the company,
for the first five or six years.
Over the last year and a
half we knew this was coming
so we commoditized him out.
There's a guy by the
name of James Orsini,
who ran for 25 years ran big
agencies, Satchi and Satchi
and things of that nature.
You know the truth is and
something I've been
talking a lot
about with my own friends,
not as much publicly,
maybe John knows, very few
people know this in this room,
maybe one or two,
I really run VaynerMedia.
Like I think because I play
GaryVee as my side hustle,
and because I'm good at it,
and because I work
18 hours a day,
a far majority in this room,
including people like Dale,
like people at Yanek,
like people I really know,
I don't think really understand
how much I actually
operate the business.
And so,
for me, every operational
decision runs through me,
I've got a lot of
context on it, I'm there.
And I think the key,
and I'd be curious and we
can maybe talk afterwards,
I think the key for me
in having a number two,
or number three, is less
about them running it
in the way that you framed it,
it's more about them
complimenting the things
that you're not good at.
Like, I'm very self-aware.
Right?
For example, knowing that
20% of you, a lot of you
don't know me, but knowing
the ones that know me
knowing that 20% of
you didn't even like me
on first impression
at a conference
or things of that nature,
like self-awareness
is imperative.
And as an operator,
I'm very self-aware
and I know where my
short-comings are.
And so I think for anybody
here that's looking to scale,
I think there's way too much
pride in this collective room,
like nobody here is
good at everything.
And that's super real.
And I think we all know that.
And we have strengths and
weaknesses and I think,
I've been a guy,
and I've watched a lot of
companies do this at scale,
I really believe on tripling
down in your strengths.
I do not, I'm not a big fan
on working on your weaknesses.
I think you have to be
dangerous in your weaknesses,
like I'm not a dope when
it comes to the finances
or the other things
that I don't wanna do,
but I'm far from
being interested
in being world-class in it,
It just doesn't leave
enough room
for you to be world-class at
what comes natural to you,
which is always
gonna have more upside.
So, it's been AJ,
it's gonna be James,
I'm building something else,
I don't know, I'm sure
a lot of you that have
bigger organizations if you're
not in a solo entrepreneur
land and if you've
run companies,
one of the things that
I realize and I realize I did at
Wine Library and I'm gonna make
it official at VaynerMedia,
is I'm gonna create something
called Office of the CEO.
So there's gonna be these six
people and they're my family,
they're the inner circle,
they're the people
that nobody else in the
company tells anything to
because they know that
the second they tell them
they're gonna tell me, right?
Everybody's got
that inner circle,
and by the way,
some of them are ranked
number five in the company,
and another person might
be number 174 salary level,
so now I'm gonna
make it official
because they just help me scale.
When there's
that level of trust,
I think sometimes people
silo a level of trust
just to your right-hand
woman, right-hand man,
like one or two people,
I actually am looking for scale,
and so I'm gonna build
a five, six person team
that basically is just
gonna take care of the thing
that's the most important
to me right now.
Like we just landed one of the
biggest banks in the country.
I can't even announce it yet.
One of the biggest
banks in the country,
it's gonna be 30%
of our revenue,
it's an enormously big client,
I really need to make
sure it goes well.
I need to put everything on it
besides the great
team I put on it.
So they'll keep an eye on that.
And they'll keep an eye
on this one employee
that I think is a superstar
and they're gonna vet it,
so the other thing I would
give a recommendation to
that has I think thematics
into were you're going,
is building an inner circle
that everybody in the company
knows is you.
Just even the five people
within an organization
in that group
won't even have
a title within it.
It's just gonna be,
that's what they are.
Office of the CEO.
Something to consider that
I see a lot of value in.
Thanks for your question, man.
- [David] Dude, David Osborne
I was born in Austin--
- Are you literally that lazy?
You just...
You couldn't go there?
(laughing audience)
- [David] Gotta
sit up front.
- Just gonna stay up here.
- [David] So...
(laughing audience)
Dude, I was born
in Austin, Texas.
Two questions:
One, what the fuck is Snapchat?
Man, I got on it because
you told me to get on it,
and I still don't know
what the fuck it is
or why I'm on it!
(laughing audience)
I know a lot of young
people follow me,
and I got no idea why--
- [Gary] That's a very common
marketers' question right now.
- The second one
is what you invest
in outside of VaynerMedia.
Do you put money in
anything that cash flows
or anything like that?
- [Gary] Got it, so...
I'll answer second one,
because it's very detailed.
I had a $25 million
venture fund called Vayner/RSE.
I'm closing one
called Vayner Capital,
that I'll be announcing
in the next month or so.
It's gonna be a $55 to
70 million fund, very different.
Vayner/RSE was 25 million,
when I made 100 investments.
So a lot of different things,
more angel investing
like I used to do.
This new one I'm gonna
raise 50 to probably
end up being 60,
70 million dollars.
I'm probably only gonna
invest in 10 companies.
So it's going to be
much later stage,
and I'm use VaynerMedia
and its capabilities
to help the outcome of companies
that are further along.
So I've always Angel--
I've made up net net
between Wine Library,
which has been a very
successful business
for a very long time,
that I get income from
'cause I ran it and
it's family business,
Vayner, I get seven
figure book advances,
and I get paid
six figures to speak.
Like with all that
lucrativeness,
the investment in Uber
and Twitter and Facebook
and Tumblr and Buddy Media
those are gonna end up
making me the most money.
So that's what I do.
And then, but...
I really truly see
myself as an operator.
You know, I will never
not run a business.
At scale, by the way.
I'll never--
And this is a fun thing
to say in this room,
I will never be
GaryVee full-time.
Like, even though
it's gotten to a place,
and it's starting
to get to a place
where I think I can make a
lotta lotta money doing it,
I just really enjoy
running businesses.
Snapchat is very simple.
I mean, it's just
attention arbitrage, right?
It's...
It's a platform that people are
consuming their content from.
There's nothing else to say.
The stories,
have you gotten to a point
where you understand--
That's the newsfeed.
It just looks a
little bit different.
You know, it's interesting.
If you take your phone right now
and look at
every social network:
Facebook, Twitter, LinkedIn--
if you consider it that,
Pinterest...
Like if you literally put all
seven of the things
we group up with:
Facebook, Twitter, LinkedIn,
Pinterest, Instagram
They all, functionally,
are the same.
It's basically one
hardcore piece of content,
and then social commentary
in one shape or form,
and then you just go this way.
Snapchat has been
the most confusing,
'cause it had totally
different UI/UX experience
left and right, up and
down, very confusing.
What's interesting
though, on the flip side,
is if we were to go
and I'm actually thinking
about making this video,
because I've just realized
this through friends and family
that are what I call
normals, not in our world.
Just like kids I went to
high school with, right?
If you go to
Times Square right now,
and you give 20 people Snapchat,
that have never used it,
within an hour,
if you help them,
they really understand it.
And just to give you context,
that never happened
with Twitter.
As somebody whose grown
up in the last 10 years,
normals never fully
fully understood Twitter,
and they really
understand Snapchat,
and they're addicted to it.
And so...
Just another place for
people to create content.
You know.
I think the bigger thing--
The reason I'm so bullish on it
and the reason in
December and January
I got very loud about it,
even though I've been talking
about it for two years,
is DJ Khaled was the cherry
on top of understanding,
and we kinda started talking
about a Vayner in September,
"shit."
30, 40 year olds are starting
to use this and for real,
and this is how they all go,
either they start in a
tech-nerd environment
or a kid environment, right?
Then they bubble up,
and then the first thing you'll
notice is 30 to 40-year-olds
in New York, San Francisco,
and L.A using it,
and then that will happen in
the middle of the country.
And then it'll
go 40, 50, 60, 70.
Snapchat's already bigger than
every other social network
that's come before it,
except for Facebook.
Already, right now.
Instagram, yes,
but Instagram's such a weird
one cause it got bought
500 days into its lifecycle.
And so it got vigged
so much by Facebook.
And so...
It's just an important
place man.
I, for this room, there's no
more important place right now
to figure out how to story
tell and do what you do.
How you communicate, what you
sell, except contextually,
you have to figure out how
that works in a
Snapchat environment.
Because the biggest fear
I have for people that are
entrepreneurs, growth hackers,
smart, doing their thing,
is we're going to not
a mobile first world.
We're going to a
mobile only world.
Right, like, I'm on a three-day
business trip right now.
No laptop, this is it.
That blows my mind.
Like, that's just crazy to me,
that I don't have my laptop.
I'm running business--
like I do stuff!
This is not like, you know,
and so
there's a lot of
people here that
rely on their tactics
in a digital environment
based on
landing page optimization
and all the things
they think about
in a desktop universe.
And so
A, what you're
doing on your website
and how you're
storytelling to the world,
you have to figure
out mobile only
and B, and probably
more importantly,
as you guys know, it's being
contextual and relevant
in all these other channels,
as well as being relevant
in your home base.
And so, that's that...
(microphone)
- [Zach] Hey Gary,
my name is Zach Obront.
Question is, I've heard you
mention before
that you think of VaynerMedia
as 650 people to leverage you.
- Yes, the scalable version
of my marketing talent, yes.
- [Zach] What's the
thinking both from
a why perspective and a how
perspective of doing that
versus the most
typical agency model
of trying to remove yourself
or make it more
self-sufficient without you?
- Well it is self-sufficient
without me.
And why don't you hold
don't you hold the mic
because there might
be a detail here.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- It's fully self-sufficient
without me.
I think, again in the same
way as your first question,
I always think the
paradox of how I run shit
and what I'm excited
about to keep you
interested for 10, 20, 30 years
Most of what it looks
like is going on isn't.
I think you'd be very
fascinated by the fact that,
I don't know,
of the 100 million dollars in
revenue from
VaynerMedia will do this year,
60 or 70 of it has
almost has nothing,
like I don't even
know the client.
Nothing.
They're not buying
Gary Vaynerchuk,
of course once in a while
they may think that,
but we're very clear
that this is an agency.
So it's very
self-sufficient without me.
But why it's the scalable
version of me
is the craft that
the agency is doing.
Meaning we're leaving a ton
of fucking money on the table,
by not doing banner ads,
by not doing search,
by not doing a ton of shit.
We probably left $25 million
straight up on the table,
by not wanting
to build websites.
When I say it's a
scalable version of me,
my main plan seven years
ago was, how am I gonna buy-
As I started meeting
Zucks and Travis and stuff,
I was like,
"Fuck I'm not these guys.
"This is not who I am."
And back to
self-awareness, I'm like,
so I'm not gonna make my money
the way they're
gonna make their money.
Seven years ago, I'm like,
"How am I gonna buy the Jets?"
Right, and so...
(laughing)
I decided that what I was
better at than all of them
was I could sell shit
better than them and stuff.
And then I kinda gave it a
lot of thought for a year,
and I said, "Huh."
There's this guy by the
name of Dean Metropoulos,
he's just a private equity guy,
but he did something
that I believe in.
I'm a very big believer
that nostalgia
is the most under-priced
asset in our society.
For example,
had I been further along,
and I wouldn't have seen it,
but had I been further along,
it would've made sense for me
to buy Marvel in bankruptcy
and then make it into movies
and make a trillion dollars.
That makes sense to me,
because the Hulk has
been around for a while.
Like, Spiderman matters.
Dean Metropoulos bought
Tuna Under The Sea tuna fish,
he bought
Pabst Blue Ribbon beer,
he bought Bazooka Joe Gum,
and then he just
runs them better and flips them.
For me, I wanna buy brands like
Snickers or PUMA or
Lacoste or I don't know,
Timex or
Peter Pan Peanut Butter.
I wanna buy brands that
have been neglected
that are under-priced.
Run them through
the VaynerMedia machine,
and then flips them, because
those are the kinda things you--
I can buy a business
for $80 million
and sell it for $4.6 billion,
if I can do what I've done in
two businesses that
I've ever run,
which is growth revenue,
extraordinarily quick.
That's what I set out to do,
which meant that was gonna
have to eat shit for 10 years,
at the height--
and again, Dan
a couple people here,
you guys knew me, like
I had a lot of leverage in 2007
'8, '9, '10,
I was in it.
When I announced
VaynerMedia Zucks texted me
and said,
"The fuck are you doing?
"Building an agency,
client services?"
I was a disappointment to all
my tech-titan friends.
I mean it!
Like, straight up
disappointment.
But, I was like,
"Cool, you go do you
"and make trillions
and change the world."
(audience laughter)
I just need to make
$4 billion to buy the Jets.
And so this is the only
way I know how to do it.
And so it look a lot of
humility and patience
to get here seven years
later and have what I have.
It also took the fact
that I had to know that
my people skills were much
better than everybody else's.
So that I'd be able to keep.
Because my vulnerability is
they could leave tomorrow.
Not building a product,
I'm not in SaaS business.
But I also had
enormous confidence
in my ability on a people level.
And so that's where we're at.
And so that's what
I mean by that.
- [Zach] Awesome, thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Ben] Hey, I'm Ben Greenfield,
fitness.com/snapchat.
(laughter)
On page seven of your book,
which I've owned for about
10 minutes now, it rocks.
You talk about how one
of the biggest lessons
that you learned in 2015 was
that you had to start taking
better care of yourself.
- Yes, health-wise.
- [Ben] And I'm curious to get
a little bit more of
the nitty-gritty details
about that, like what'd you
do as a busy family man,
entrepreneur to start
taking care of yourself?
- Well John why don't
you come up here, and why
don't we tell
this story together?
(laughter)
- [John] I was hoping
you'd say that.
- You got it.
- Is there a mic up here?
- Yeah, let's get a
mic for this man,
this man has a
lot to do with it.
Let's clap it up for this guy.
(audience applauds)
- Hey, guys.
This is very exciting.
- I'll let him take over
at some point, 'cause he'll
know where to take over,
I'll give you the context.
Basically,
super-fuckin' random,
like just random fuckin'
flight from
San Francisco to New York.
I'm just sitting there
and I'm like you know,
when am I gonna take care
of this health thing?
I know that it's not right,
I know I'm not winning,
I got into a good place in
my head around my health
where I looked at it like
a business, and I said
I'm not doing the behavior
that's gonna make me successful
and eventually this
is gonna catch up,
and the weird thing is,
it got to a place where
I was like, wow,
I don't do anything right.
I eat like shit, I've never
worked out once in my life,
and somehow I can literally
work 18 hours a day
and not be tired, and my
fat is equally proportioned
through my entire
body so it's hiding
(audience laughs)
how fat I am and like inside
I must be fuckin' Yokozuna
from WWF but it's
not like, you know.
And so, I just started
talking to myself,
I talk to myself a lot,
and I was like,
I need to address this.
So that's what I said, and
then the flight's delayed.
Super funny, it happens,
no big deal.
And I'm just talking and
talking, and I was like
you know what, when
I turned 30, I freaked my shit
with Wine Library and
I started Wine Library TV
and got into tech and I
completely changed my behavior.
On my 30th birthday.
Driving to Wine Library,
looking in my rear view mirror,
I'm like, literally this is
what happened, my birthday,
my 30th birthday,
I looked at myself dead
in the mirror, in my rear
view mirror, and I said
"You're fuckin' full of shit."
and what I would say to myself,
talking to myself I was like,
you say that you're gonna
buy the New York Jets,
none of your behavior
maps you pulling that off.
And so if you're gonna do
it, you better lay down
some serious foundation
from 30 to 40 because
family's coming and all this,
right, so I said to myself,
"Wouldn't it be romantic
if on my 40th birthday,
"because I don't think
I need another,
"what am I gonna work,
from 19 hours a day to 24?"
I was like, that's not
gonna be it, I was like,
you know what, health.
That'd be a really
good one to address,
let me get my
shit together there
and literally before
the flight took over,
I said, 'cause I was
38 and four months old,
I was like, fuck it,
why wait 'till 40?
I'll do it at 39.
And then, literally,
I was like you know what,
fuck it, I'll do it
as soon as possible.
And so that happened
about a year and a half
after we met
where I tried my first version
of what I just told you,
which was I decided to go
the peer pressure route,
and I publicly Tweeted and
Facebooked that I wanted
to get a trainer that's
when you took over.
- Yeah, so this is 2011,
I think?
- Mhmmm. Maybe '12.
- It was right when
Thank You Economy came out.
- Okay '11.
- 2011-ish and Gary and I met.
he was giving a talk at
the Apple Store in SoHo,
I went down in my Jets gear
which is not like me blowing
Gary, I'm just a big fuckin'
Jets fan to my ever-lasting
dismay and so we met,
we chat a little bit, just
rapport building relationships
and as most people do
inappropriately,
he commented on my physique,
turned out I was trainer,
give him my card,
which he then lost.
Couple week later--
- I threw it out.
- Yeah, fuck this.
(audience laughs)
'Cause at that point I was
like, 2011 John was like
I'm super professional,
business cards.
I should have just
fuckin' Tweeted at him.
And then, he put up on Facebook
that he needed a trainer
and so people did
what is inexplicable to me,
people who follow Gary,
instead of leveraging
what they do,
they all just jumped on
that Facebook thread,
pick me, pick me, pick me
and the shit that Gary
talks about not doing.
And so I was like fuck that
and I just posted on my Facebook
and sent everyone
on my page over
to blow up his
thread and so then,
I got an email
maybe 20 minutes later
from Phil Torano who was
then Gary's assistant
and that Monday, I was
in the gym with Gary.
So the plan, initially,
was to train
four to five days a week,
for an hour
and then Gary made it a
habit of cancelling on me
at least three times a week.
And I let him off the hook.
It was really cool to
be working with Gary.
But we do a lot
of work together.
And then--
- That story, I'll jump
in, so that's right.
Because, by the way,
and I talk a lot
about it in business,
for some of you
that are following along.
I talk about
religion over tactics.
I just wasn't in
the religious place
to take care of my health.
I was half pregnant,
that's why I cancelled.
I'm publicly saying
I never get sick.
He's supposed to work
out with me at 6:30,
at 6:22 I'm like, dude,
I'm so sick.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, mother fucker.
I was in West Village
at the time
going to the Upper East Side
like a $40 cab ride.
And it's like,
this mother fucker.
It's like, it's cool bro.
- We built a really
nice relationship
and when I made that decision,
the first thing
I did was call him
and I said, "I need your help."
And what my plan was,
was what I realized,
by the way, in that moment,
was I was not held
accountable to myself.
- Right, and so he
called me and he's like,
"I have this crazy idea."
"Tell me if it's retarded."
"What I would like to
do is hire someone
"to be completely
in charge of my body."
"I want to bring
them on full time
"as staff and
they're going to be
"in charge of my food,
"they're going to
travel with me,
"take care of my
workouts and everything."
And I said, "I think
it's a great idea
"if you don't fuckin'
cancel on them all the time.
"But you also have to
find somebody who's good."
You got to, someone who
sits in the venn diagram
of being good enough for me
to feel comfortable
recommending them.
I had moved to L.A.
at this point,
I was no longer
eligible for this job.
And they have to
be good enough,
they have to be at a
point in their business
where it makes sense to
only have one client.
It needs to make sense in
all these different facets.
And so, the only guy
I could think of
was a kid who had started
as an intern for me,
he became my
prodigy and then started
his own business, Mike Vacanti.
And so Gary had
trained with him briefly.
- That was the worse four months
like two sessions.
- Yeah like in four months
he had like three sessions.
And so, I was like,
"Mike will kill it for you."
He really is,
he's a great trainer
and a phenomenal dude and I knew
that he had the
right metal to be able
to work with Gary
and travel with him
300 days out of year at points.
And so that's how it started.
And so Mike became
the CEO of Gary's body
and since then,
Gary has made tremendous
physical changes and it's also
given him a lot more energy
and that's more or
less the gist of that.
- Has not given me more energy.
I'm just fully, fully, has not.
(audience laughs)
- He's less broken than he was.
- No, no, I mean look, look.
I mean, do I expect a
57 like I'm not naive
that there's so much good
that's supposed to
happen but like,
I never want to say things
that haven't happened.
I don't have more energy.
What I do have,
is at least my left
glute is now active.
(audience laughs)
That is something I have now.
Who knew that a glute
could go so inactive?
Go sit down, I got more to do.
- Here you go man.
- Thanks, good to see you,
love you bro.
(audience claps)
So, the answer is and this is
how I believe
about every business.
I talk a lot about
fitness entrepreneurs
who are so good
about their physique
and their regime and all that,
but then, in their business,
their looking for the secret
or the 12 courses that
don't let them do the work.
Once I made the
religious decision
to do the work and I had
one interesting unlock
that maybe can
help you in some way.
I figured out,
in that really zen place.
I was like, fuck,
it's 'cause I'm not
competitive with myself.
I don't give a shit
if I run four minutes
and nine seconds and
yesterday I did 4:11.
I'm competitive with everything
in the world but myself.
And so I realized
I needed to be held
accountable to another human.
I work out every single
day and don't cheat.
I've been unbelievable
'cause I don't want
to let Mike down.
And because,
I know every morning
I'm going to go on the scale
and Mike's going to know.
I've suffocated
myself and by the way,
Mike's tenure of
two years all-in,
is done July seventh.
I have a new guy
starting for three years.
And I'm very comfortable
in saying this,
if I was ever to stop doing it,
I would revert back.
So many people after
six months or a year,
they're like, "All right Gary,
"you don't need Mike anymore."
"You got it now."
I'm like, "Absolutely not."
It's the accountability
to another person
is what was the
break through for me.
- Cool. Yeah, you
got it brother.
- [Man] Hi, Gary.
- Hey, man.
- [Man] I'd like to
ask ask about chatbots,
do you think that's gonna
be the next big thing?
Should we be
investing in chatbots?
- Like bots in general?
- [Man] Or,
messenger as a platform?
- Yeah, I mean, look.
It's huge in Asia,
there's enormous
opportunities for bots
to make life more scalable,
things of that nature.
So yeah, do I think bots in
messaging apps are a pillar?
Yeah, I do. And I think it's
gonna take 3, 4, 5, years,
for it to be a real scale,
but it's talking about
search in '01 or email
in '96 or social in '07,
I think it's a real genre.
And here's what's
more important:
it's kinda like Google
Glass or other things
that have not worked out,
whether it works or not
AI and automation
will never stop.
We're gonna become robots.
So, whether bots on messenger
become the way you win
is far more irrelevant
than the fact
that you get the taste
of what the concept is,
so that if in
two to four, seven,
nine, 14 years from now
it's VR augmented execution
that breaks through for you.
The thing that pisses me
off is how many of you
have not used Snapchat 'cause
you "think it's a waste of time
"in case it's a fad"
and you don't realize the
tasting the execution
sets you up for the next thing.
I wasted, I wasted a
fuckload of time on Socialcam
because it was a fad
except it taught me 90%
of what made me successful
on Vine and Instagram video
and Snapchat, and so please,
enough of "well what if
this is here tomorrow?"
Who gives a fuck?
It's here right now,
milk it for what it is,
learn what it means,
and it's gonna
iterate on top of that
and that's why I think bots
are massively important
for this group, not because
you figured out what bot
to make on Slack
or on Facebook Messenger
to build your business,
but because you'll learn
what bot thinking is, how
humans interact with augmented,
and then learn
from that and ideate.
You got it.
- [Dave] Hey, I'm Dave Asprey,
The "Bulletproof" coffee guy.
- Hey man.
- [Dave] Hey.
You mentioned earlier
when you were hiring
a personal trainer
CEO of your health
"pick me! Pick me! Pick me!"
All over the place, right?
I'm dealing with
the same things.
What do you do
to prevent the people
from coming into
your circle who are there
as basically brand parasites,
they want to be there for
three months, six months,
say "hey, I worked for Gary V.!"
and then go out and
build their own brand
and probably steal
half your shit.
How do you get around that?
- So, first of all,
I get around it
by not being crippled by it.
So I'm just not
worried about it.
It's a cost of entry
and it's a byproduct,
and I'm actually flattered by it
to be very frank with you.
So mentally that's where I'm at.
Number two, I'm never
worried about stealing.
It's interesting that you
brought that up.
I try to give away all
my shit all the time.
Like to me,
one thing I've learned,
is that 99% of people
won't do anything
with your information anyway.
(crowd murmuring)
It's all execution and
especially what
I do for a living,
I'm trying to figure out
new platforms of attention
quicker and better
than the market, so --
I mean, by the way,
pre-rolled YouTube video.
There's 9 years of content
of me saying it's shit
except six months ago
Google changed it
and now you can target
people's Google search behavior
in pre-roll video and all
of a sudden it's fucking good
because I know exactly
what your intent is.
I don't give a crap about
Google's bullshit demographics,
no longer am I crippled
by "are you really
"a 33 year old African
American female in Houston?"
I don't give a shit.
I know that you searched
the Houston Rockets so
I got what I need, right?
So you know, the truth is
I've got it in a mental box
where I understand.
The one that's probably
bothered me the most is
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook".
I wrote a book called
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook"
give give give, and then ask.
Unfortunately, so many
think it's give give give
and then take. Even
more scary, I don't like
when I watch people give
me things I don't want
and then expect me
to give them things
and then be like, "What up, bro?
'Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook?'"
I'm like, "Fuck you dude."
(crowd laughs)
I didn't want you to send
me your bullshit t-shirt.
I don't consider your
fuckin' piece of shit t-shirt
a jab dickface.
(laughter)
So, I would say, look,
and I think more
importantly I'll give
you one other slight tweak
that I actually think
is more helpful than
anything else I've said here,
and this will help
a lot of you I hope.
Because it's been huge for me:
it's never the hiring.
Too many people here
are crippled by hiring
and making the right call,
it's about the firing.
So if you're gonna let
somebody into your inner circle
don't worry about what
their intentions are,
if they're full of shit,
once they get in
if you can taste it,
get 'em out.
Got it?
- [Dave] Thank you.
- You got it, brother.
- [Dev] Hey Gary.
- Hey, man.
- [Dev] My name's Dev,
I'm a search guy,
and I wanted to ask what
are some of the keys
to new business
growth at VaynerMedia?
You guys scaled immensely
fast over the years up to
a hundred mil, right?
So what were some of the
keys that basically led to
growth of new business?
- The pillars that
got us there were,
number one culture internally.
I'm a big fan of
B and C players.
I'm gonna give
you a lot of things,
like the hiring and the firing,
another one that I think has
that same ethos is that
I'm actually very fond
of average players on your team.
If you go for scale.
If you're gonna build
a four person company,
y'all have to be ninjas.
I get it.
But if you're building
a 700 person company,
you don't have 700 As.
As a matter of fact, if
you really break it down,
anybody that works for
someone else isn't like you.
There was no me working for you.
So number one,
it was the acceptance
of not being crippled.
First, hiring
ultra-fast -- ugh.
The hiring process
at VaynerMedia is,
"Are you alive? You're hired!"
You know?
(crowd laughs)
The truth is, it got a
little bit better than that
when I got out of the equation.
But when I hired
employee 30 to a buck 50,
people barely got
off the elevator
and I was like,
"Here's your punch card."
A lot of the early
people knew who I was,
and they thought
it might be hard --
I mean they couldn't believe it.
I was like, "You like sports?"
"Nah." You're hired!
(crowd laughs)
It was just whatever because
I realized we were growing.
And here is something very
interesting:
one thing that you have to
understand is,
you can't be the judge and
the jury for the market.
One of the reasons I grew it so
fast was
we were so ahead of the market
with social media marketing
and strategy that even if
they were B and C players,
I knew they were A players to
the market.
So my B and C could walk
into Campbell's Soup
and seem like a super A.
So I think one of the things is
if you're great at search,
what you need to understand
is who you're selling to
may not be as great as you are.
And please, I wanna make
sure I'm being very,
this is what's great about
having time
to give these
detailed answers,
I'm not talking about selling
stuff you don't believe in.
You gotta understand
a lot of people,
you know what's funny?
I had a lot of "no" men
and "no" women around me.
For somebody's so hyperbolized,
I like people who will
push back against me.
I need the context. So a
lot of them pushed very hard
in 2010 and '11 of, like,
"Gary, what's the--"
right in my team, like
does this mean anything?
Does this help the client?
And I educate him, like look,
and this
was before there was paid social
that could drive the
business results we have now
so it was very organic, I go,
"look,
"here's what you
have to understand.
"They're paying us
$5,000 dollars a month
"for the amount of content
and strategy we're giving them
"and just the IP for
60,000 a year is a gift
"for these companies.
"They're paying
$5,000 dollars right now
"for the catering bill on
their bullshit commercial."
So it's about contextualizing.
One was the culture,
keep continuity.
The amount of people I have,
our voluntary turnover
rate is 75-100,
like it's unbelievably
better than the market.
Two, it was my
brand leadership as a,
I mean, I had a real,
what do you mean I had,
I have a real fuckin' racket.
I get paid $100,000
dollars to go and speak
and then land million dollar
accounts.
That's fucking good, you know?
(crowd laughs)
You know what I mean?
It was funny,
I saw you shaking your head
to some stuff right now.
I always pay attention
to who's vibing with
me when I speak,
and I use their positive energy
to keep my momentum going.
This one Toyota talk,
small group this size,
it was just one
guy giving me vibes.
Mentally, I'm like
"I'm gonna go thank
"that guy after this talk."
Guy ends up being the
fucking CMO of Toyota.
This was a dealership, like,
northeast steelers, you know?
The speaking, my brand.
And then finally, and this
will always be tried and true,
as charismatic and
as cool as I am,
as much as
we have continuity,
there is no 100 million dollars,
there is no 30 to 650 people
three-to-100 million
revenue in four years
without doing good work. So
the biggest growth we had,
the biggest,
was somebody at
Pepsi being blown,
Lipton, Brisk Ice Tea,
South By Southwest 2009.
Seven weeks after
Instagram came out,
we made Instagram
cans for Brisk Ice Tea
for South By Southwest,
it got them a lot of
press, Instagram blew up,
that guy left and
went to Mondelez
and hired us, right?
In corporate America people
are leaving and going
to different companies
and hiring us --
the key to our
growth was word of mouth
of our good work when people
went to other companies.
Yeah. You got it, brother.
- [Man 2] Hey man.
- Hey man.
- [Man 2] Family
question for you,
I'm not sure if
Mark has asked you this
at the Social Media and
Marketing World or not.
But I know you're really
good about keeping weekends
to yourself.
- Yes.
- [Man 2] Four or
five years from now,
your kid says,
"Hey Dad, you're not around
"as much as I'd like you to be."
- I'm super scared of this
conversation, by the way.
(audience laughter)
I'm being dead serious.
- [Man 2] Yeah,
I am too, I mean,
our kids are the same age and--
- Keep going.
- [Man 2] What, you know,
does it change the plans--
- I don't know.
- [Man 2] To buy the Jets,
does it--
- One thing, I was super
excited about being here
because when I get to do long
Q and A with a lot of people
that have some sense of who
I am and there's a high caliber
of individuals, A, I'm never
interested in bullshitting,
B, I think I'm even at a
heightened degree of not wanting
to bullshit,
if that makes any sense.
I don't know.
Like I am not interested
in lying about this issue.
One of the things I think
some of you have noticed,
is I'm starting to talk
about suicide and depression
in entrepreneur
land 'cause it's real.
A lot of, most especially
looking at this room,
at the age group that a
lot of us are in this room,
there's less fake entrepreneurs
here than when I go
to the Y Combinator
event in a couple months.
Like, it has become such
a popular thing to sell.
There are so many 22, 23,
24-year-olds that are truly
not entrepreneurs that
are being entrepreneurs
'cause it's the
cool thing to do
and what it's leading to,
and the cliche,
and this is of course
generalization,
but the thing that I've
seen because I'm very in it
right now is a lot
of the 24-year-olds
that are in
entrepreneurship are the people
that can raise, you know,
$3 million or $1 million to do
it and a lot of those people
are rich, white dudes.
Okay?
And the cliche thing with a
lot of these rich white kids
that are 22, 23, 24 starting
these internet companies is,
they grew up
in a private school.
They went to a big time college.
Mom and Dad facilitated
a lot and the first time
they've ever dealt
with any true meritocracy
or market conditions is the
day their app hits the market
and the market says, "Go fuck
yourself," almost every time.
(audience laughter)
And it's this, we have, and
a lot of you are parents,
or are gonna be parents.
We have an absolute wrong
game right now in our culture
in America, by the way, this
happens to every empire.
This is what's happening to us.
It's black and white.
We are in the eighth place
trophy business right now.
We just are.
We're rewarding
kids because we think,
we're doing fake self esteem.
It's the politically
correct thing to do.
And my wife knows, I don't
give a fuck about anything
when it comes to what the
kids are doing in school
but when they go and
do camp or sports,
no eighth place trophies.
Like, my little guy Xander,
he's got a little basket
in our apartment, he has never
made a single basket on me,
nor will he until he's
15 or 16 years old.
(laughter)
I'm being dead serious.
Because it's not life.
It's just not life.
(laughter)
(applause)
It's true, it's true,
he will never score.
He's got a weird
complex already about it.
And so, I think that
we're living through a very
interesting time right now
of depression and suicide.
There's been three suicides
in the tech ecosystem,
the hardcore tech
ecosystem that we know
and nobody talks about it
and we need to talk about it.
And there's a lack of
self-awareness right now
in the game and
I'm worried about it.
And I forgot about the
question because I was wrapping
that back to something.
What was it again?
Oh, if they say, so on that,
I think you've got
to talk real truths
and so I don't want to bullshit.
If my kids say that,
I don't know.
I don't know what
I'm going to tell them.
I know that I was a lot more
scared of it a year or two ago
until I realized that,
(laughs)
this is just so fucking real.
Oh, I'm getting to a wealth
level where I'd be able
to grab my kids from school
on Friday and fly private
somewhere for
three days with them.
I actually am so curious
if I'm going to get caught
in the middle.
I do believe, and I've
watched very carefully,
that there's a financial
arbitrage level
where you can buy time at
such an incredible pace
that you might be
able to sell it back
to that time together.
Know one thing,
I haven't missed a recital
or an important school event
for my first grade daughter yet.
You know.
If I'm in New York, which means,
luckily I'm not traveling
300 days a week.
I've missed stuff
but I'll never miss it
if it's controllable
and the other thing
I'm very fascinated by
is a lot of my friends
spend time with their kids
but they're not spending
time with their kids.
So like, a lot of my
buddies are absolutely like,
will razz me, and then I'll
razz them back and be like,
"Dude, I was over at
your house the other day.
"You're not with you,
you play Call of Duty
"when you get home from work."
Like, you're not with your kids.
Listen, I'm going
to say another thing.
There's a couple things that
I'm absolutely adamant about.
I will never give you,
I will never judge,
forget about give you,
I think we all like to spew
a little advice.
I will never judge
somebody's relationship
or how they parent.
I'm the by-product
of immigrant parents,
where I didn't even see my
dad until I was 15 years old
and he's my best bud.
We have the greatest
relationships of all time.
So, of course I'm
effected by that, right?
Of course I'm effected by,
"Shit, my dad got away with."
But I'm also
not taking for granted
that my kids are wired
the same way that I was.
I think it's an
always moving thing.
So, I don't know, man, I don't
know what I'm going to do.
But I really,
I just know my truth
which is if I'm not happy,
then everything else breaks,
and if it makes me
unhappy not to hustle,
and do my thing,
that's a vulnerability.
And that's a real
truth that people
don't want to say out loud.
Which is, I know what the
politically correct thing
to say here is, I know what
everybody wants to say,
but I'm suffocated not being me.
I'm suffocated not being me.
And my kids are way
worse off if I'm unhappy
than being happy, and so,
I don't want to let them down.
I'm pretty, I'm already,
listen, I'm taking seven
weeks vacation a year
and it's hardcore quality
time in that seven weeks.
And then with weekends,
I actually weirdly think
I need to work more.
I'm like, "Fuck, there's
two days a week."
I don't know.
I'm concerned about it
because I don't know
my kids well enough yet, right?
I don't know where,
like I know the way
Lizzy and I are building
them and I'm hoping
with the DNA that they have,
that they're going to be
extremely self confident
and self worth and a lot
of those kind of things
that will keep them into
a place where that won't be
as much of an issue or
concern or their worth
won't be wrapped
up in my behavior.
And I mean that.
Like, one of the things
that my wife and I share,
and it's probably the
foundation of our love affair
with each other is we
don't fucking give a fuck
about what anybody thinks,
including each other,
think about each other.
(audience laughter)
I came home the other day.
I was like, "Liz, you have to
tell me about your side dude.
"Because you really
don't give a fuck."
If I texted Lizzy
right now and was like,
"Hey, ran into Jordan and
Dan and John at this event
"and we're going to go
to Korea for nine months
"to work on this new startup."
She would literally text
back in like two minutes
and be like, "Do you
want me to pack?"
Like it's unbelievable
to me how much
she's an enabler
of my behavior.
(audience laughter)
I mean it, I mean it.
And she does her thing
and so, I don't know.
And it's the most interesting
variable in my life
but I'm convinced
that I will never go
as far as
"the market wants me to,"
because I know myself too
well and I just won't be happy
if I can't do me.
(applause)
- [Char] Hey Gary, it's Char.
It's just a question
related back to your point
about nostalgia being
really underrated.
- Yes.
- [Char] And then bringing that
back into some of the new
social media platforms and
I wonder what your view is
about voice coming back?
So apps like Anchor which
I think, personally,
are really interesting
particularly for--
- Me too.
- [Char] For a different
demographic, so I'd love to know
what you think about--
- The problem with
voice, and I love voice,
and I love Anchor, I've been
watching it very carefully
as I know you know.
It takes too much time.
We like time more than context.
So why voice is incredible is,
do you know how many times
you misinterpreted a Tweet
or an email?
A fuckload.
'Cause tone is lost in writing.
What Voice does incredibly
well is you won't lose it
because that's just
something we know.
The problem is, I have
no interest in listening
to anybody's Anchor here
because it takes too much time.
That's the problem.
So, I'm bullish on voice.
I mean, from 2008, '9,
'10, '11, I was like,
"Ooh, voice Twitter,
voice Twitter."
Anchor is the first voice
Twitter that I've seen.
Problem is it
takes too much time
and time is becoming, like
every second that goes by,
time is becoming more valuable.
Like we are willing to pay
unbelievable amounts of money
to buy time.
Uber's built on it.
Uber sells time.
Uber sells the
perception of time.
Like you think the car,
in New York City,
the amount of times
I have an Uber coming
and just watch cab after
cab after cab drive by.
(audience laughter)
I'm like, "This fucking blows."
You know, so.
Time is, I would tell
you that if you're hungry
to actually build a start
up, I tell everybody
to build time apps.
100%.
Anything that sells you time.
That's why the Postmates
and the same day deliveries
and all that stuff,
time.
- [Alex] Hey Gary,
Alex Icon on Snapchat.
Thanks for selling
me on Snapchat.
- You got it, brother.
- [Alex] Yeah, the question
I want to ask,
you talked earlier
about leveraging Vayner
into buying businesses.
- Yes.
- [Alex] So when are you
going to go all-in on that
and what are the businesses
you're going to start with?
- I don't know.
I don't know what businesses
I'm going to start with.
I've been looking at deals
for the last 18 months.
I even got into
one letter of intent
but I didn't like the
way the numbers looked.
So first of all,
number one rule is,
it had to be big at one
point and it's not right now.
Right?
So, Bubblicious Bubble Gum,
did $128 million in revenue
13 years ago, 17 years ago,
now it does seven, right?
So there's a lot of
things like that.
Like Green Giant food
sold not too long ago.
Fila, remember Fila, for
all you hip hop heads
and Grant Hill fans, it was
big for 48 seconds, right?
Like Z. Cavaricci pants, John.
(audience laughter)
It had to have brand
for a certain time.
By the way, this is how
the toy business works.
Like, My Little Pony,
for anybody's who's 40,
like I am, or in
that general range,
if you go in the toy aisle
now, it's our toy aisle
because we're parents now
and we'll be nostalgic
and we want our kids to play
with Strawberry Shortcake
and GI Joe and Star Wars and
My Little Pony and dadadada.
So, it has to be underpriced,
had to have a lot of revenue,
and my preference would be
that it would skew
very strong 13 to 30
because my marketing
behavior usually starts there
and it's underpriced there.
So any brand that
you want to sell to,
if you want to sell
something to an 18-year-old
in America today and you
don't spend 90% of your money
and energy on Snapchat and
Instagram, you're an idiot.
That's where their attention is.
And that stuff
is always underpriced.
Snapchat and
Instagram influencers
and Snapchat marketing
are underpriced, grossly
underpriced right now.
The way search was
grossly underpriced
when I started doing it in 2001.
And there's long
tailed search SEM's
that are underpriced by the
word wine is not five cents
a click any more.
And Facebook advertising
24 months ago
was the greatest steal in
the market when I was yelling
about it and everybody was
like, "No, they took away our,"
everybody got romantic.
They took away
our organic reach.
Who gives a fuck?
They took away your organic
reach and they give you
the best ad product that
ever existed in return.
Same thing right now,
you're debating Snapchat.
It's a fad, dadadada.
And then in 24 months
you're going to be on it
and you're going not
land grab as much,
it's going to be harder
to build fanbase.
It's going to get noisy.
The early users are
going to stop buying.
It's just the same fucking
pattern recognition forever.
You got it.
- [Cole] Hey Gary, Cole.
- Cole, what's up, man?
- [Cole] What's up?
Quick first question for your
fund, the $50 to 70 million?
- Yeah?
- Is it open to
outside investors and
what's the maximum
offer or buy in?
- So yeah, we still
haven't closed.
The minimum is a $2 million
check and super happy
to talk to you about it.
- [Cole] Perfect, thank you.
Bigger, sorry,
that was just real quick.
Bigger question, was
talking to Yanik today
and you know about
Thrive where he spoke,
what do you think about
someone who's in a startup
including a social element
or a give like a Tom's Shoes
in the startups today
for the millennials
that seem to be, and again,
what Yanik was citing today,
research that they're more
inclined to buy
from someone that makes
a difference than someone
that's just making a profit.
- Yanik's right.
The problem is
marketers ruin everything.
(audience laughter)
So what's happened is,
my data shows,
and what I'm looking at is
that the trend is already
swung the other direction.
You know, Yanik, I don't know
what, if you look at the data
but I think what's happened is,
there was probably three
months there a year ago,
where every startup, and
I look at seven to 25 startups
a week because I invest,
came in and said,
"Gary, Gary, I got it,
all right, listen.
"I have an umbrella company.
"It's an umbrella and for
every umbrella you buy,
"we give an umbrella to
some poor dude in Seattle."
(audience laughter)
You know like, and
so what happened was,
when Tom's Shoes did it, and
when a couple of the early
people did it, it was novel.
It caught our attention.
Yes, the younger set does
care more about charity
and giving and,
you know, no question.
They're wired differently.
The problem is,
it became a tactic.
Every scum bucket
marketer that I know
started a startup that had
a buy one get one, give one,
and it became tactical and
now there's 8,000 of them
out there and
now it's just noise.
It's the same old game.
Supply and demand and so,
I think there's an opportunity.
The problem is
where's the intent?
So many people now do
it because they think
it's the hook for their
business to succeed,
not because they actually
give a fuck about curing
a disease or helping somebody
in an underprivileged
environment and when your
intent is fucked, you lost.
And that's real and
you guys know it.
And you also know that
you've done many things
where your intent was
wrong, it was tactical,
and it never wins.
So, if your intent's,
what's that?
- [Man 3] Amen.
- Amen, brother, thank you.
It's true and so, I think
can somebody tomorrow
start a company that's
buy and give and win?
Absolutely, if it's their truth.
A, it's harder to break through
because there's so much shit,
and B, unfortunately
there's just not so many
people that have that truth.
- [Man 4] Hey,
it's me again.
- Does he get more air time?
Strategy.
- [Man 4] This is a
prediction because I know
you like to be right about shit.
Do you think Snapchat
will add at any point
in the near future something
for sort of endemic discovery
rather than having to push
people from other networks?
- I don't know.
And I do like to predict,
and I feel comfortable.
The reason is,
Evan's done so many things.
I don't know Evan well enough
to know what he's going to do.
What I do think is that
Snapchat's gonna do
something very smart in
the way they're doing
the stories thing.
How many people here actually
like Snapchat and use it
as a human?
Like, not as a marketer,
that's me.
I mean, as a human you like it.
So you notice how they went
with continuous stories,
I think they're going to
do a very smart ad product
in between people.
So that's what
I think they've set up.
That I'll predict.
I think there was
no reason to do it
except the continuous
content gets stopped.
And I think it's
really cool if you go,
if you really think of data,
think about,
you follow GaryVee and
Tim Ferris, and you can actually
buy an ad in between
those two people.
You can buy an ad between
Kim Kardashian and Toyota.
Like, you'll have the data to
know what the continuation is
and you can insert
a five or 10 in there.
I think if you could do
that, boy, I would buy
the shit out of that
if I actually knew
the two media entities,
I would just understand
who that person was and
what they were interested in
and be able to create and
sell in that environment.
- [Man 5] Two questions,
three questions left.
- No, we could
do a little bit more.
I'm going to try
to be late for my call.
This is too fun.
(audience laughing)
- [Diana] Hey Gary,
Diana here.
- How are you?
- [Diana] I'm great,
how are you?
- Good.
- [Diana] So if Snapchat's
on this side,
I kind of see
meditation on this side.
- Okay.
- [Diana] I know you're
very kind of futuristic
and have made
quite a few predictions--
- I have.
- [Diana] On the
meditation side.
- Obsessed.
- [Diana] I'm really curious.
How do you see meditation
playing out as a consumable
in the marketplace?
Is it events?
- Yes.
- [Diana] Is it online?
- [Diana] Everything.
- Yes.
Meditation is the fitness
industry over the last 20 years.
- [Diana] That's you
think it's going to be.
- Meditation in 20 years
is a foundational pillar
in American consumer society.
Mental health is the
next physical health.
Everybody here in
20 years will have some,
there'll be the
lightweight version of it,
like oh, there's some cool
little app and it just makes
me sleep better or escape,
and then there'll be
more extreme stuff.
And the truth is, just so
everybody knows,
and I appreciate
you knowing that,
and people that follow me.
I know really nothing about it.
I just know consumer behavior
and I know when I see
the tea leaves, I just
know it is going to be,
there is, I'm 100% positive
that the next retail explosion,
like that looks like Soul Cycle
or like Blockbuster Video
is going to be, there is
going to be a Starbucks
and Soul Cycle of meditation.
The place that every trendy
rich cool person goes to
and sits there.
(audience laughter)
So I think, think about it as
every other genre that pops.
So there'll be the
Starbucks and Soul Cycle,
there'll be you
have UFC fighting,
there was the
merchandise company,
they'll be the Tap Out
or the Life is Good.
There'll be a brand that owns
the meditation swag, right?
And then there's going to
be all the other things.
I think it's going to be big.
Like, as a matter of fact,
you guys heard earlier,
the $50 to $75 million
10 companies,
one of them will be a
major bet on meditation.
I don't know what but I will.
E Sports, VR B2B,
I think virtual
reality's being sold
as a consumer
thing way to early.
It feels like Internet '91, '92.
So I think it's way to early
but much like in '91, '92,
the people that made money
were like the infrastructure
of the internet itself.
I'm very hot on
virtual reality B2B.
I'm very hot on meditation.
I'm very hot on e-sports
and I'm very hot on fully
integrated direct to
consumer products.
- Yeah, hey man.
- [Chris] Thanks for
being here tonight.
Chris Caplin.
The stump question for you
tonight was around
your children.
- Yes.
- [Chris] So, I have a 10 year
old girl who's going on 25
and a 12 year old boy who
I just gave an iPhone 6 to
without a data plan.
But wants a Snapchat account,
has an Instagram account.
And what are your thoughts
and ideas on our youth
and their just obsession
with social media?
- [Chris] I know it's inevitable
and I want them
to be a part of it
'cause they teach
me to be a part of it
but how do I--
I don't want to be a
helicopter parent either.
How do we control
the 4,000 fucking
passive aggressive
assholes out there
who tell my child
horrible, horrible things?
- Right, they're fat, or ugly,
or what--
So a couple things.
One, I truly believe the way
that we always
solve every problem
is the religion not the tactic,
back to the question
about fitness,
so I think that if you've
been able to instill
the right pillars into
your child, you win.
Like, it's unbelievable
how much peer pressure
wasn't able to penetrate me
because of what my parents
did in building that self esteem
and things of that nature.
Look, this is evolution.
Like, you know,
when I was a kid,
girls that got second phone
lines, that was gonna ruin them.
Like they were
gonna lay in their room
and be on the phone all day.
Or Zelda was gonna
fucking make me
like not capable of
being a human in society.
(audience laughs)
Like, you know,
whether it was video games
or whether it was punk music
or rock and roll in the 70's
or whether it was
Elvis shaking his hips.
Like, I mean, what
Miley Cyrus did four years ago
on the MTV Music Awards that
got everybody freaked out,
is tame on Instagram.
Like, evolution.
And so I think you've got to
instill good principles
into your kids.
It's unbelievable how many
parents have come
to me and said,
"I'm not letting my
son on Snapchat."
Right, because they're
scared of sexting,
because that was the
headline for Snapchat.
Meanwhile, like, "Does your
son have a phone?" "Yeah."
"Does he have the
internet on his phone?"
(audience laughter)
"Yes."
I'm like, you know he can go
to jizzhut.com pretty easily.
(audience laughter)
You know so, I think that--
I promise you,
that's far more dangerous
of what you're scared of,
than the random 12 year old
floozy chick in science class.
(audience laughter)
I think the way you solve
everything, by the way,
is communication.
And I think a lot of parents
are scared to have real talk.
And so I think you
have conversation.
And look, a 10-year-old
and a 12-year-old
is still a 10 and 12-year-old.
You have to be observant,
but it's gonna be what
it's gonna be, man.
Listen, the funny thing is,
I don't know if it's because
I like so don't want to die
and stay so
grounded to my youth.
Or because I'm in this stuff.
I'm sure you guys all
feel the same way, like,
we were just there.
Like I was just in sixth
grade spending four months
trying to figure out how to
steal Playboy's from 7-11
with my buddies.
You know, it was just
two minutes ago.
So like this--
I think we love our kids
so much, we go on defense.
It's the way people
run their business.
When something gets
good they go to defense.
And that's the
second they start losing.
And so I understand why,
and I feel those things too,
but it is what it is.
Conversations and instilling
the right things into them.
And my big thing actually,
is more I'm gonna watch
my kids to make sure
they're not the kids that
are doing the bad stuff
to other kids more so like--
I want them to feel the adver--
I'm actually okay with
getting their feelings hurt
and things of that nature.
I want to have those
conversations.
But like this obsession
with protecting our kids
from getting their feelings
hurt is a little too far.
Like I want Xander to get
punched in the fucking mouth.
(audience laughs timidly)
I do!
(audience laughter)
I think it'd be good for him.
He's just a rich kid
from the Upper East Side.
Fuck, he needs a good beating.
- [Man 6] Hey Gary.
So often I work with
a lot of entrepreneurs
and successful
different people and stuff.
And it's not always
but more often than not
there's a cost often.
Kind of they're
unaware of the cost
that the brand
building has created.
So while you've been crushing it
and I use that term obviously
because of your book.
And with respect
I've read your book
and I kind of hated the book
because it showed me
how to do something
I was scared shitless to
do in such a simple way.
And I'll never forget the
day I posted my first video,
and thanks for making me look
like a total asshole
in the world.
Because I tell you, I put this
video out and it was so bad.
But I was so scared
and you simplified the
whole process for me.
And it's gone on to
do different things,
and I'm very grateful for that.
But I work with a lot of
very interesting people
who often have a lot of success
and I was gonna say, to
be politically correct,
there's oft sometimes
not a cost,
but the reality is, almost
every time there is a cost.
- There's always a cost.
- [Man 6] I'm just wondering,
and I'm not trying
to expose you,
but I'm just wondering
from your point of view
if you wouldn't mind sharing
a degree of that cost
or you know if there is
a cost in your point.
- I mean, the cost is--
There's a lot--
I actually, when I really
think about your question,
the biggest cost
I'm worried about
is if actually
I do something wrong.
So for the most part,
I don't do anything wrong
by our standards in society
and I'm scared that I've
done such a great job
of building, to the
people that know me,
a very good thing,
that I'm scared of like--
I always think, like
what could slip me up?
I think about that a lot.
As far as to answer
your question directly,
what's been the cost?
Well, leisure.
You know like, it's fun
to like do fun stuff
and like I don't
remember the last time
that I was fundamentally
completely calm.
(audience laughter)
Let me explain what I mean.
Everything's on me.
My whole family, my brother,
my two brother-in-law's,
my brother, my parents, my sis--
everybody's livelihood at
this point, and lifestyle,
is on my shoulders.
The whole kit and caboodle.
Like that's called pressure.
And then if you really like
are wired the way I am,
I genuinely care about the
people that are in my ecosystem.
Even the people that
are like employee 432,
I feel pressure.
I feel pressure, so the
biggest cost I think is peace.
Like when you're the one,
you know like,
this whole notion of like
being the entrepreneur,
I don't know--
And I see a lot of you
shaking your head,
like you guys,
you gals know, it's on you.
It's super fun to be number two.
Like I always bust AJ's chops,
I'm like, "you've got the
fucking gig."
Because like when the
whole thing's on fire,
like you still can go,
"What are we gonna do?"
(audience laughter)
- [Man 7] That's true.
- Right?
For me I think the
biggest thing I gave up
was like it--
it's very--
And I'm doing it right now--
Man, it's been you know,
eighth grade, ninth grade,
it's been a long time
when I didn't recognize
that not only my life but
pretty much everybody else
I gave a fuck
about in the world,
was predicated
on my behavior, period.
Like for real.
So peace of mind and like "ahh."
That is just, you give that up.
And I've given up a ton.
I mean, the first five
years of my marriage
is one of the great
regrets of my life.
Like because I was
hustling so much.
I easily and should've
and desperately wish
that I went on two more
weeks vacation with Lizzie
to Paris and Japan and
just ate sushi for a week.
Like, and I didn't.
And I don't get it back.
And so it makes me very
conscious of the kid stuff
and so I've learned
from that behavior
and I've been much
better with the kids.
Seven weeks vacation, still.
I don't even like
saying it out loud.
And there's other things.
Friendships.
There's a lot of good
friends that I have
from high school and college
that I don't have a
relationship with anymore
that would have been
very fruitful in my life
that are just gone.
Pressure's tough man.
Right?
But for me and for a
lot of people in here,
there's just no other gear.
You're just,
your destiny's your destiny.
So I'm not naive,
I don't think it's
so great being me.
I really don't.
I love being me,
but I recognize why me
is not great on paper.
Like I truly believe that
there's a much sweeter spot
in our society than
the one I sit with.
I romance it as the guy or
girl that makes like 347 a year
as a solid exec, has a
ridiculous work-life balance,
goes to every fucking
little league game,
has four weeks vac--
Like you know.
But I just don't know that gear.
I don't have that.
- [Man 7] Sorry.
Do you think
that people like you exist
to pull people into the gear
or the middle
ground where they can--
- [Gary] I'm sorry?
- [Man 7] Do you think
people like you
need to exist in the world
to pull people into a space
where they can have a
bit more peace of mind?
In other words, that you
pay a price for that.
And this is a very
personal question,
because, despite the fact that
I'm always in front of people
and speaking or whatever,
it's very, very extremely
lonely to do what I do.
- It's the loneliest!
- [Man 7] Yeah.
- Dude, there's nobody else.
Like, if you're truly, truly
the number one of your thing,
there's just, what else?
Like, who? Where?
Like I talk to no--
Do you know that I never
talk to my wife about work?
(clicks tongue) Goose egg.
And I think that
the people in here
that have that
same thing, they realize,
what are we gonna talk about?
99% of my day is fires.
I'm in the business
of eating shit.
(audience laughter)
Do I really want to come
home and tell my wife that--
Like, I don't celebrate victory.
Like, the biggest
vulnerability--
One of the weakest things,
one of the things that I'm
doing worst in my company
is we are killing it and
we don't celebrate dick.
Like we win an
account like, "yeah."
We don't even talk--
Like, I don't know.
All I do, all my energy
is spent on the negative.
It's what I do.
It's what you have to do.
Because if you don't
address it, it becomes cancer,
and becomes your vulnerability.
And so, I get it, brother.
I think there's a huge
price to pay, you know?
A huge price to pay.
But I would not have
it any other way.
I'm happy as shit.
Because I'm living the
game that I was built for.
But this is why I'm so
scared of the reverse.
I'm scared of the people,
the cliché thing is everybody
right now at Princeton
who five to seven years ago
would have went
to Bain and McKinsey,
made a lot of money,
met another attractive smart
person at Bain and McKinsey,
married them, bought a
second home in the Hampton's
because one made
740 at fucking Goldman
and one made 297 at this.
That same fucking person
today is starting a start-up
and has the Uber for maids.
(audience laughter)
And is gonna lose.
Is gonna lose.
Is gonna take a three
to six year set back.
Is gonna lose equity
in their ecosystem.
Is gonna have a
bruised confidence.
Because they weren't--
I'm, as an entrepreneur,
as a one,
I only want to lose.
Like, losing is comfortable.
Losing's delicious.
That's why I love
being a Jets fan.
You know, like--
(audience laughter)
So, I'm worried actually,
it's so funny who I'm trying
to talk to these days,
is the people that aren't
built for what you and I know.
Because it's super glamorous.
This is why I'm visceral to
what's going on on Instagram.
And you've been
hearing me talk about
the bullshit
entrepreneurs who rent!
Rent watches, planes,
girls, baby giraffes,
(audience laughter)
and then sell people
on how they got it
because they
allude to they having it,
versus renting it,
and then selling bullshit
and they're selling
entrepreneurship that
that is not what
entrepreneurship is.
It's just not.
(applause)
Keep going.
I think we're getting somewhere.
(audience laughter)
Thank you, brother.
- [Steve] Hi Gary, I'm Steve.
I'm a behavioral profiler.
(audience laughter)
I don't wanna ask a question
as much as I want
to make a statement.
- Okay.
- We need you
just the way you are.
Now, I know there's a
lot of questions probably
in some peoples heads in
here about your style,
the way you do things,
but you're basically
created this way
and there's people in this world
that wouldn't do shit if it
wasn't for people like you.
And so I just want to
encourage you in the fact
that you know you're thinking
about your fatherhood
and your husbandry and all
these different things.
But they hooked up with
you being the way you are.
- I get it man.
- [Steve] And that's you and
I want you to be proud of it.
- [Gary] I am.
- And I know that.
- [Gary] I really am.
- I just want to say that--
- I appreciate that
- [Steve] for everybody else.
- And, listen--
- This is who you are, you're
like a modern day prophet
for the business world.
And Elon Musk is another one.
I mean, you're an anomaly.
You're not normal.
- Listen--
- [Steve] I say that because
there are social norms
- [Gary] I get it.
- You're so far outside
of the social norm
that you stand out,
you become an anomaly,
and everybody's
freaked out at it.
But it's who you are,
it's what you are.
And stay being that.
- You know, my man,
I think you'll find this
interesting based
on what you do,
I'm so in-tune to that,
that I've had very intense
conversations with my wife
which is, people not
having self-awareness
or being blind to it.
I know that the way I'm wired
is the cliché thing
where there's that person
that's super famous
and they die and then
like the country mourns
and then the family goes,
"Yeah, but there
weren't there for me."
Like I'm so conscious of that,
I'm so aware that I'm for scale,
that I know it comes at
the cost of those 10 people
that I hack at it a lot because
I'm trying to figure out
like, "boy do I know?"
And it's a crazy
feeling to know it.
Like it's a crazy feeling
to hear thanks for--
Like, I don't know.
You know what else by the way?
It's super easy for me not
to get caught up in it.
Like, I didn't do anything.
My mom and dad had sex
at the right second.
Like, I didn't do anything.
Like this is who I am.
This has always been
who I was, even--
It's so fun for me to
have my grammar school
and middle school friends
pop up because of Facebook.
They're telling me shit
that I long forgot
and it's just the same shit.
Like there's something about
the way that I communicate
that makes people see
it slightly different
and then allows them to
do something with it.
And so I'm not
running from it, I just--
If I can do anything to hack
not doing the cliché thing
that happens to people like me,
which is the people closest
to me lose the most,
the people furthest away
from me win the most,
I'd like to at least do that.
But other than that,
I just don't even
know how not to be me.
- [Steve] (mumbles)
- Well thank you.
(audience laughter)
- [Melissa] So to that end,
Melissa Lands
of the Fresh 20, to that
end, I'm a little nervous
to ask this question in
a room full of HD men
but, so, do you think that
there's room for women?
Like what's your prediction
on women changing
that dynamic and going
from the crush it economy
to the live it economy and
kind of changing the dynamic
of what it means to be a
successful entrepreneur?
Do you think that women are
going to make that change
in business or not important?
- So I want to make
sure I understand it.
So, give me a
little more detail.
- [Melissa] So for most of the
highly successful
women entrepreneurs
that I know, they're not
concerned about crushing it,
they're concerned about
living a holistic life
so that you--
- You mean with children,
go in detail.
- [Melissa] No,
not even children,
just having a little
bit more of a balance.
Being more connected to
the people on the ground,
to their friends,
to their family.
Like living in a way that
they don't have to make
the sacrifices
that you're making.
- Yeah, look, I mean, 99% of
the dudes don't want to do
what I'm doing either.
So, look, a couple things.
One, boys and
girls are different.
- [Melissa] In what way?
- [Gary] And so like, this has
been a very interesting topic.
VaynerMedia was built
on female leadership.
I wrote the first check to
Birchbox after they had 50 no's.
Like, I have a higher percentage
of female entrepreneurs
in my ecosystem and
I get all this credit
and I feel terrible about
it because the reason
I've done these things is
I'm actually prejudiced
against dudes in a
world where I think EQ,
in a world where it
has been proven that EQ
is not more
favorable to a woman,
I'm being prejudiced to
guys that they can't be
as EQ oriented as women,
even though I am.
So, what do I,
I think it's first of all,
look how far we've come in
America on race and gender
in 30, 40, 50 years.
It's really good and
there'll be more
and I think that
it's really cool.
When it comes to business,
it's so sports for me,
that you would be,
like it's stunning to me
how I cannot even
wrap my head around
even thinking of anything
other than the market.
You know?
Like I never would think,
"Oh, you're a Hispanic.
"Oh, you're a transgender.
"Oh, you're a Black dude.
"You're a girl."
I would never think,
I don't care.
Can we win?
Can you fucking sell shit?
And so, I think that,
one, I think a lot about
if I was exactly
my way as a woman,
how much would starting
a family pull at me
from a chemical
we're different game.
I'm fascinated by that,
just like in general.
But I think that
a lot of White males
really, really, really worry
about what other people
think of them and
they have it best.
So I'm very empathetic to
what a woman's going to think
about what everybody
else thinks about them
and I think that's holding
people back.
Boy, girl, Black, White, more
than anything in the world
and so I do think,
I think that's the key
to the question
that you're asking.
Once a person is capable of
really getting into a place
where they're content
with themselves
and can, at a very high level,
not worry about the market's
feedback to themselves,
they can win.
In whatever they want.
And so, "living it,"
first and foremost,
is defined super
different by every person.
And so, that's just
how I see it.
But it's funny, it's really
an interesting issue.
It's a really interesting
genre for me.
My daughter is much more
similar to me than my son is.
I can tell that already.
And so, I want her to be,
if she wants to,
I want her to be number one
and I don't want anything
to stop her but I also,
pretty interesting about this,
and I say this to my minority
and female entrepreneurs,
if one person, one, if
one person in the world
that looks like you ever
achieved it, then you can too.
Like, there's this big
argument right now
with a lot of my
female entrepreneurs.
They're like, "It's so
hard to get money
"from White man VC's."
I'm like, "Getting VC
money is nothing compared
"to the market."
(applause)
The market's much
tougher than Dickhead Don
on Sandhill Road.
- [Melissa] But I think
you misunderstand
my question so
I didn't do it right.
- So let's do it.
- [Melissa] My question's not
about women equality
because I think
that I can do anything--
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- [Melissa] That any man in
this room can do.
- [Gary] Go ahead, yup.
- [Melissa] And maybe better.
My question is, do you think
that women business leaders
are going to change the culture
from the crush it culture to--
- No.
- [Melissa] No at all?
- Nope.
(audience laughter)
- [Melissa] Awesome,
like it's interesting.
Because we're living in this
world where our concerns
are different.
- I don't think the crush it
culture is really the culture.
Really, I don't.
It's just one of the
sub-cultures.
There's much more momentum
for politically correct.
Just so you know because a
lot of my content goes viral
on Facebook, which by
the way, it's so funny,
a lot of my content is going
quite, scaling quite well
on Facebook, by the
way, here's the secret.
Captioned videos.
Do not put up another
video on Facebook
without captioning it.
So there's a tactic for tonight.
Anyway, my content is
dismantling it.
Which is so funny
because my paid team,
my team sits next to me
and I'll know
because we're
putting up content.
We're very much in sports
culture, like yeah,
they get excited,
they're super pumped
and I'm super sad
for a quick second
'cause I'm like, "Fuck, here
comes seven million people
"that have never seen
me before so here comes
"the top 15 comments of
this guy's a fuckface."
You know?
(audience laughter)
Here's why I brought that up.
All of my content that's
"crush it," that's winning,
is viscerally getting
pushed against.
Like the top thing
that everybody does,
do you want to see your kids?
This guy's going to die at 42.
You know, like, I do not
think that crush it culture
is the main culture right now.
I think the work life
balance, politically correct,
we're all going to
accomplish fucking everything
and do everything
balanced right game
is the culture.
And Bernie's very popular,
right?
Go look at the data, I'm
looking at it very carefully
'cause I don't want
my head chopped off
for being a capitalist.
16 to 24 year olds, for all
the entrepreneurs there are,
there's a bunch of people that
think working hard is bad.
Like capitalism is bad,
like you're in an ecosystem
of a lot of winners, crush it,
we're going to fucking do it,
but the macro,
the macro, the thing
has already changed.
The thing's changed.
America lost.
Like just, I want everybody,
I don't know how much
you get around, it's over.
We've had too many decades
and too many generations,
you, me, we're the problem.
Like just, it's not our faults.
We were just born in the
generation of 200 years
into our empire.
We are soft.
Soft.
(applause)
- [Man 8] Gary, you
talked quite a bit
today about self-awareness.
How do you build and
sustain self-awareness?
- I don't know.
I hate this question because
fuck I really want to give
a good answer and there's
people that do different things.
Like, I don't feel like I have
a grasp on how to teach
self-awareness or maintain it.
I know I have it.
I know I rely on it.
I know that there's people,
I've seen people talk
about how to do it.
Like, I respect that
that may be true,
I've never dug under the hood
or watched somebody do it.
I have seen this and this is
something for a lot of you
that are building
things to think about.
I have seen a lot of my people
grow in their self-awareness
out of the safety that I've
created in the environment,
in the culture of the
company and so within safety,
they've been able to expand
their emotional intelligence.
But I don't know, man.
But boy, let me tell you
something, for that gentleman,
or whoever else,
if you know how to do it,
if there's a
way to really do it,
it's the drug.
It is the game.
It's unbelievable how
powerful it is if you have it.
It just saves you.
Makes you likable,
makes you like yourself.
It makes you understand shit.
The other thing,
you've got to understand,
there's something that
comes along with it,
there's a cousin of all
these feelings, empathy,
is something I live on.
Do you know that nobody's
ever let me down?
If you really understood
why I'm so damn happy,
and I really am, it's because
nobody's ever let me down
because I actually have
zero expectation of others.
Like zero.
Because I understand, I get it.
I'm empathetic.
I understand, I get it.
You couldn't, you shouldn't,
you weren't raised that way,
you didn't see it,
you didn't like,
I don't know.
I'm not sure but
I can tell you this.
If I could wish besides health
on my children two things,
it would be unbelievable
self esteem which I do think
I can control and then
I wish it was unbelievable
self awareness which
I don't understand
that I can control as much.
- [Man 9] Hey Gary.
- How are ya?
- [Man 9] Great.
I'm going to take
this opportunity
to get some free life coaching,
so thank you, in advance.
I founded a successful company,
and if I keep doing it
for a few more years,
I'll have hit my number,
and I'll be done.
- Right.
- [Man 9] The problem is,
I have this
burning desire to
be on the Snapchat,
and like, giving advice,
and helping
young people, and all that?
- Yeah.
- [Man 9] But I don't have
the type of business
where that
would like, feed into,
leads, or anything like that,
so it's a bit dilemma for me.
- Yes.
- [Man 10] Do I start
doing that now,
or do I keep grinding,
and try to like,
hit this financial thing?
And my girlfriend
asked me last night,
she's like, well, if you died,
what would you be happier about,
having that dollar
in the bank account,
or having your book published,
and helped a
lot of young people,
and I was like, oh, fuck.
(laughs) So, I just wanted
to throw it out and--
- Seems like you
found the right girl.
(laughter)
I think, I think,
I think my answer to that is,
you should do both.
I don't, like,
what I would do if I were you,
and what I normally do
in these situations,
is I would audit the rest of it.
So like, let's get real,
are you willing to get
very real with me?
- [Man 9] Let's do it.
- How many hours
do you work a day?
For real, don't bullshit me.
- [Man 9] Six.
- Do both.
(laughter)
- [Man 9] Okay, thank you.
(laughter and applause)
- Because eight
is a fuckin' half day,
(laughter)
and that means you...
And that means that
you have two hours
to do all that good, and
that's fuckin' awesome, really.
You know what's funny?
I want what you want, too.
I, it's what I do, so
much, unfortunately for me,
like, that's what cost me 16,
yeah, you know what I mean?
So, you should, I mean,
if you, if you truly,
if you wanna shoot it
black and white straight?
You should do both,
you should figure out
how to get to eight,
hopefully it doesn't
take time out of, time together,
hopefully it's coming out of,
I don't know what
the fuck you're doing
with your other, fuckin'...
(laughter)
"House of Cards",
surfing, I don't know
what the fuck
you're doing, but like,
like, two hours
a day you can find
to give advice,
and do that stuff,
and it's, it is, it is you know,
it's so funny, like doing that,
doing the whole
personal brand thing,
and being out there,
it's such a double win.
Like, depending
on how much vanity,
and like, that stuff
you have in,
it gets to scratch that.
I mean, I was waiting
for my car today in LA,
some dude was
flying down the highway,
almost died, pulled over,
and was like, "Gary V!"
And just left, like, that's
the biggest high, ever!
(laughter)
Like, I was so pumped!
And then, on the
other hand, the fought,
the other, and it's an
equal, I don't think
it's better, or worse, for me,
I mean,
we're all wired different.
The emails of people,
like, hey man,
you really helped me, like I was
signing up for all this crap,
I did this,
this happened, you know.
It's so,
it's intoxicating
for people to email you,
and say that
you changed their life.
I have that happen to me
every day now, it's crazy!
You know? It's crazy.
So if you feel like,
if you're feeling
a yearning towards it,
you should do it.
- [Man 9] Awesome, thank you.
- Yeah, man.
- [Man 10] Gary,
you talked about fires,
and fighting fires,
and I think that's
a battle that probably all of
us do on a daily basis, right?
So--
- Yes.
- [Man 10] Well now,
I have a two part question,
one is, what do you
fuck up on, often?
- Yes.
- [Man 10] And when you lose,
how do you not lose the lesson?
- How do I not lose the lesson?
So I love losing, and
I hate losing, right?
They're like, polar opposites.
So the thing I most
fuck up on, is that
I think I can do everything.
I have big eyes, you
know? Fat kid cake. Right?
Like, I just have big eyes.
I just, because
I work so much,
and I work so hard,
and so intense
I always think that
I can pull it off, so,
sometimes I'm just trying to
do 78 things, and you can't.
That's my common mistake,
I'll always do that.
Its, because
somewhere deep down,
I still think it's working out,
'cause I think
it's a net-net game,
but it is where I fall short,
on more than a micro level,
probably a,
three fourths micro,
all the way up to macro.
For me, I never,
I mean, I don't know
if it's the same
reason that I remember
everything that's ever happened,
like I remember everything.
Like, I remember Flowtown.
Like, like, like you know?
Like, I remember everything.
Like just, fuckin' everything.
And so, I,
because of that, I guess?
I don't lose the lessons?
Because I can never, ever,
understand why
someone would knowingly
make the same mistake twice.
So. Yep.
- [Man 7] You still
good with time?
Yeah, I'm fighting it.
I pushed the call for a second.
- [Woman] Thank you for this.
- You're welcome.
- [Woman] I wanted
to ask you a question,
in fact, you were talking
about self-awareness.
- Yes.
- [Woman] And, where
do you get most of
your self-awareness
is this one of the
things you feel
like you've had--
- Yes
- Or is it life lessons,
is it really the shit,
like, the hard moments?
Can you give some
examples of where
you've had some--
- I think it started--
- [Woman] Big awakenings?
I guess, right?
- Yeah.
Yeah, you know what?
So, I realized somewhere
around sophomore
year of high school,
that
suddenly way more
people than I wanted
found me annoying.
(laughter)
That was probably the
first time I was like,
maybe I was losing that like,
I remember back,
I remember early high school
being like, wait a minute!
They're not highly entertained
and finding this interesting?
(laughter)
So, I do remember,
I think it's DNA.
I don't know where I get it,
I don't, but I,
when you said that,
like, I do remember,
from 12 to 18,
I found my way,
how to make this,
more palpable, and
I thought really owned it,
and got great at it, until
I became more of a public
figure,
and every time
I fuckin' post a piece
of content on
Facebook it goes viral,
4,000 people
say I'm a dick face.
(laughter)
So, you know,
I think that I try to
deploy self-awareness
as much as possible,
and now, I'm self-aware
that 20% of people
on first impact
(laughter)
are not gonna like it.
And so, I do think it came
from the lessons of life.
Like, I think one of the
things that one has to do,
is accept themselves, right?
And I think once I'm,
once I did that,
then it didn't hurt
so much to have 20%,
two out of 10
people not like it.
Because the cool thing
with me is I also
have three out of 10 people
that like it so much.
And think it's the coolest
thing they've ever seen,
and you just play it out,
and then for me,
because I know I'm grounded in
very good truths,
and principles?
I get a second at-bat
at it which is,
it's so rewarding for
people that thought
you were a douchebag, to
turn, and become an advocate.
I would tell you, probably the
50 biggest
advocates I have on social?
Initially hated me.
- [Woman] Okay. So was
there, like, you know,
a lot of people are in fear--
- Yes.
- [Woman] Of being
authentic, right?
- Yes
- [Woman] They don't even know
necessarily, who they are,
or even the
unknown unknowns about
their own personality.
- No, that's a really
good point, that's right.
- [Woman] Okay. Okay.
And so, but you, you have just
always had that, what would you,
what advice would you?
- I just tell people
that they're gonna die.
You're gonna die!
- [Woman] Are you
gonna die right this--
(laughter)
- You're gonna die,
[Woman] - Okay.
- And at 91,
when you're sitting
there, and you're like,
"You know what? Fuck!"
(laughter)
I mean it!
One of the,
this is interesting to me,
this is where,
this is where hard wiring
is something
I believe in tremendously.
It took me, again, when
this started all happening,
my 20's and 30's
and 40 and then I've
started realizing this,
boy did I fuckin',
was I attracted to
old people as a kid.
Like, one of, I don't know
if any of you did this,
and, then maybe we have
some connections that way.
I was weird as shit,
like, I, like, like,
my friend would be, like,
I grew up in the 80's,
when, which meant, you
played outside, right?
And so, when we
were outside playing,
grandparents would
visit once in a while,
and maybe 'cause I didn't have,
my, both my grandparents,
three of my four
grandparents died
before I was born,
people die young in Russia,
'cause they didn't
wanna fuckin' live.
(laughter)
And so, and so,
maybe that's why?
And I used to think
that's why, but now
I just realize,
I mean, I learned a lot
from just talkin' to old people
and I think I picked
that up, at like,
you know what I smelled?
Regret.
And I'm gonna
tell you something.
As scary as it is,
for you to judge me?
And for you to not think
I'm cool, and this and that?
What's way scarier,
the thing I've,
I think one of the scariest
things in the world,
is regret.
You know why?
You can't fix it.
I can fix you thinking I'm
a dick face over the time.
I can't fix being 96
and becoming 64 again.
And so, I think I'm so
visceral to the regret
that I smelled on
old people as a kid,
that it impacted me heavily.
Yeah.
[Tanya] Hi, I'm Tanya.
- Hey Tanya.
- [Tanya] I work with
teen entrepreneurs,
have four of them here,
and I was just wondering
if you could give
them a piece of advice
as kids that are in high school,
- Yeah.
- [Tanya] 15, 16 years old,
that are running
successful companies,
trying to balance, you
know, everything in life.
- Yep.
- [Tanya] Any piece of advice
that you may have for them?
- Yes. Kids?
Don't listen to Tanya.
(Tanya laughs)
Don't listen to your parents,
definitely don't listen
to your fuckin' teachers,
(laughter)
don't listen to me,
listen to yourself.
And I fuckin' mean that.
(applause)
You'll learn, if you're
wrong, you'll learn.
And it's much better
to learn by tasting it,
than reading about it,
or being told about it.
That's my advice to 'em.
- [Tanya] Thank you.
- You got it.
That's, and by the way,
that's advice to
entrepreneurs, right?
Like, that' what you, like,
that's not
advice to operators,
who are going to be
CEO's of Fortune 500 companies.
They've gotta listen to parents,
they've gotta, like, they're
gonna play that game.
But if you're
an entrepreneur, there's,
it's binary, you've gotta
go completely the other way.
'Cause the market's the judge.
And it's back to what
you and I talked about.
When you're the
entrepreneur, it's lonely.
You know,
Mom's not there to save you.
- [Woman 2] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Woman 2] (laughs) I'm a
New Yorker and a Jets fan,
so, let's go Jets.
- I love you already.
I also love your hair.
- [Woman 2] Oh, thank you!
- You're welcome.
- [Woman 2] I think
you kind of, sort of
answered, sort of what
I was gonna say,
I'm kinda new
to not giving a fuck?
- Okay.
- [Woman 2] It's a
new thing for me?
- Yep.
- [Woman 2] It's
kind of happened--
- But has it always been there?
(laughter)
- [Woman 2] Yeah!
- It's always been there, right?
- [Woman 2] Yes! I was
like, always nice to people.
- But you're like, you know
what, I like this guy--
- [Woman 2] Yeah,
I've just kinda left--
- I'm nice to people!
- [Woman 2] No, no, no!
(laughter)
I know, but I also,
I feel less responsible
for people's feelings.
- Let me tell you
something real quick,
and some of you know this.
I'm only
razzy on stage when I'm not
talking to anybody individually.
I'm actually very
uncomfortable with
confrontation on
a one-to-one level,
and I would never,
ever think about
hurting somebody's feelings,
for, like, why?
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- You know, so--
- [Woman 2] I'm with you.
- You know? It's just when so--
I'm more visceral
when somebody else
is doing something to someone.
I'm more of like,
he's being mean to him,
and I'll, that's when
I'll jump in, you know?
- [Woman 2] Yes. And I
don't mean just being mean.
- I get it.
- [Woman 2] Although,
I have no problem
with confrontation, whatsoever.
(laughter)
I'm a lawyer, so it kinda,
and a New Yorker.
- By the way,
you know what, I apologize,
my, I would actually argue,
my biggest weakness is,
ever, was my lack,
my visceral reaction
to confrontation which
made me very bad at firing,
for about 10 to 12 years,
because I was terrible at it.
Like, I was terrible at it.
I was so full of shit, like,
I would never give
any critical feedback,
and then you just
walk in and be fired,
because I've got pent up,
enough courage to finally do it,
I was terrible at it.
And it, and I was
really bad at it.
And it's something I'm
very embarrassed about.
And the worst
version of it, is it's
how I broke up
with girls, and I hate
to say it out loud,
(laughter)
because I wanna be
really, like it was,
it's the single thing
I'm most embarrassed of,
of the way I broke up
with girls that I dated,
because I wasn't a man enough
to break up to their face.
That felt good.
(laughter)
Good to get the, good
to get the poison out.
(laughter and applause)
All right, go ahead.
- [Woman 2] We forgive you.
- Thank you. (laughs)
- [Woman 2] So,
my question really is,
like, what's the ROI
on not giving a fuck
and being
apologetically yourself.
'Cause that's--
- Speed.
Speed. The thing that you,
when you're not
spending any time worrying,
you're spending
time on executing.
Speed.
And I like the way a lot
of you reacted to that,
because that's a weird
answer to that question.
But I can see that
a lot of you caught it,
and some of you
understand it and do it.
Speed is the game in what
we all do for a living.
And if you're not worried
about dwelling
on what people think,
you're in execution mode.
And I do everything
in my possession,
everything in my power,
excuse me,
to put myself in full
execution mode at all times.
- [Woman 2] Awesome. Thank you.
- You got it. All right, now
I have to go. I love you guys!
(cheering and applause)
I had a lotta fun, a
lot of fun. Thank you.